[Laughter]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by pusha t he's a
five-time grammy award-nominated artist
including his latest record daytona
which was up for rap album of the year
last month he released his new single
diet coke which can only mean one thing
a new pusha t album of the year
contender is on the way but in the
meantime a 10 round bout with the wings
of death pusha t welcome to the show
thanks for having me how are you around
hot sauce before we dig in i'm just
curious where's your foundation i'm
pretty mild i mean i'm a you know i'm a
texas pete guy
i'm a
[Music]
tabasco sauce i mean nothing too crazy
well today it'll be a crash course in
all things hot sauce are you ready to
get started yeah let's get to it
[Music]
[Music]
okay
and then it's already on oh it's already
on it it's already on oh man
easy easy
cool
easy
so for the last few weeks you've been
giving people a steady dose of new music
from the song snippets to putting out a
music video for your latest single diet
coke what's your relationship between
taking time off between projects like
separating yourself from the spotlight
it's rare in this social media age of 24
7 accessibility to have an artist of
your caliber lay low for any amount of
time
i just feel like you know
my brand is all about creating like
masterpieces
and
i don't know if masterpieces get churned
out
every every six months or every nine
months or every year actually
some good music can come from it
but i'm i'm very specific on what it is
that i'm trying to create what i'm
trying to make
well that is a lovely segue to the next
wing are you ready to move on yeah
so this next one is the dawson's cedar
smoke garlic okay
[Music]
that's cool not too tough
[Music]
so recently we had dave grohl on the
show who's a big believer that music is
shaped by its physical surroundings
there's so much lore between the hawaii
sessions from my beautiful dark twisted
fantasy to recording daytona and wyoming
and utah what do you think the influence
is of a place on a record sonically like
how are those albums products of the
recording environment
you know going to those secluded places
whether it's hawaii
whether it's utah wyoming it's um
[Music]
[Laughter]
um
that's really just to get away from
people
and to really be able to hone in and
focus on what it is that we're trying to
create i've noticed that when we stay in
major cities
too many distractions too many
distractions too many people coming over
you know
when really we're just trying to like
really cook up and and
and you know create perfection you're
meticulous about putting together a
comprehensive body of work but some of
your collaborators are a little more
spontaneous
what comes to mind when you think of the
last minute suggestions kanye west has
had when your album to say due and 24
hours to the label
oh man um that's that's the thing about
him i think that's that's the the gift
of him his instincts
he's pretty spot on instinctively when
like he just feels like a song is
missing something or feels like the art
is
not as strong as it could be
and the good thing about him is he works
to the last minute so you always get
that opportunity to be great
hmm
pretty easy there we go yeah enjoy that
and the wings are great they are grape
wings enjoying the sauces enjoy that
while you can over here on this show
so hustler music has remained classic
over the years but the trappings of the
lifestyle have evolved over time so what
i want to do is play a game where i just
hit you with some things straight out of
a hip-hop time capsule and you tell me
if they're primed for a comeback baby or
if they need to fall back baby okay
acura legend coupes
come back or fall back
man
i'm not gonna front on that man come
back
come back i love those cars just a super
innovative shape you know it was a
staple just in the streets like you you
were you were actually doing your thing
if you had it
you know what i'm saying i know what
you're saying
throw back jerseys
oh fall back
fall back
i just don't want anything to do with
the throwback jersey i don't know and
they were just so oversized and crazy it
was like
i don't know if we need that
g-shock watches
um
you know what
come back i'm on the edge of my seat oh
yeah come back come back come back with
the g-shock man i mean you know it's
calm it's it's cool it's um it's every
day there we go yeah and then when you
think about the cars the watches the
designers that have defined various eras
in your rap career is there a pusha t
brand cosign that you think is age the
best like when you think about the waves
that you were on early on are there any
that you look back on and are most proud
of hmm
i think workwear has has really done me
well
like all my albums all my album
packaging and all my album uh
art and pictures and press pictures are
usually like workwear inspired and i
would say uh hot ones fit of the year so
far oh
yeah you like the color right there yeah
angry goat pepper company okay
[Music]
so you grew up in virginia beach miles
away from music titans including
timbaland chad hugo pharrell missy
elliot and that's kind of just off the
top of my head what's the significance
of hovercraft studios on shell road
wow
hovercraft studios um it's where a lot
of magic happened um
hovercraft was a studio that pharrell
and chad bought actually
[Music]
that um
it was it was listen man
it was it was a studio we used to work
out of and eventually they they
purchased it
virginia beach in the whole 757 area
had a lot of different influences right
i think that's interesting right because
you have like the military base nearby
so you're not like locked into regional
sounds that you'd find in california new
york or wherever else so i found a lot
of um there would be like a mixtape um
store
and i'd go to it and they would have
like
introduced me to things like texas screw
music and things like that because they
were catering to the military
and um i was just you know i was
introduced to a lot of different a lot
of different sounds that way
cool no problem no problem
that was a setup
well i think you've noticed by now that
sometimes you'll eat a hot sauce right
it'll be okay at first and then it has
that sort of like ticking time bomb
quality to it we're 30 seconds down the
line or whatever that's when you really
start to feel it right and then you ask
these questions and i gotta talk through
like my saliva
yes it's tough
so you've made the same song and same
album your whole career a point that you
make with pride is the music is timeless
but there's also something remarkable
about finding new angles on a singular
subject like a push or t study in the
elasticity of the english language do
you see a connection between your brand
of articulate street raps and then like
an artist who's done a thousand still
lifes or a poet who focuses on nature or
war
no i don't
i don't and just recently i was saying
that like i am like the martin scorsese
of like street raps
and that's how i want to be seen like
even just creatively scorsese gives you
the departed goodfellas and a host of
other joints and you never say hey i
want him to make a love story
that's how i want you to look at me rap
wise
because it's still
at the end of the day like i always kick
it up a notch i always keep it relevant
to today's time i always still give you
the uh
the right here right now version of
everything that you know
that uh is the foundation of what it is
that that i do street rap wise
[Music]
is is hot sauce is your thing like you
do this all the time yeah believe it or
not we're like in the tail end of the
17th season so for like seven or eight
years i've been doing the show oh so
you've like done this like you know like
this is your thing it's just a lifestyle
for me
yeah
now tell me something what about like
when do i get to like drink water or
soda or milk so there's nothing you can
right now if you'd like to okay and uh i
kind of have a habit of mirroring the
guest so like whenever you go in i feel
like then i can go in too you know so
whenever you're ready i'm gonna join you
at the party tyler
it's interesting to me that in the
beginning of your career you do 2000
shows for drug dealers and then ended up
doing the pitchfork festivals to an
audience of hipsters looking back what
did those shows feel like while you were
doing them the pitchfork shows and then
looking back now what impact do you
think it had on like the trajectory of
your career ah man at the listen at the
time when i was doing those pitchfork
shows
i was like really upset at that time
because i was like that's not what i was
used to
but fast forward looking back in
hindsight
it really helped establish my base
we called them clipsters um they
understood and they read deeper into the
lyrics than just coke
i think those days and those times and
and that audience
really helped shape everything that's
going on today
[Music]
this is like hot for no reason
so i'm not really interested in
re-examining headlines from three years
ago but i am curious your thoughts on
the evolution of rap beef and how you
think the rules of engagement have
changed over time what would you say is
the biggest difference between how diss
tracks were exchanged 20 years ago
versus today and why is it still
important who wins um
it's really corporate now
so it's like
now like you'll have like a rat beef and
like
a record label gets involved and like
the ceos are like oh you can't do this
to my artists
and they'll like
i don't think they end careers anymore
because people don't have the same like
pride level about the art is it less
important who wins now than it used to
be yeah cause like
you know
back in the day it was like career
ending
you know what i'm saying there were
stakes
yeah because it was based around the art
now nowadays like man they don't people
don't care they're like oh well you know
he lost today but
whatever it's no big deal you know we
don't we don't care as much we're just
moving on and so you know so many
headlines and things going on and just
sweep it under the rug
well
speaking of moving on this next one is
the bomb beyond insanity and i should
note no water no milk
no grape soda through seven
yeah let the record show
this next one might change some things
this is the bomb beyond insanity really
you sure
you're very confident no i'm just asking
you ready i'm ready all right come on
ruined a great wing it's not even good
[Laughter]
it's kind of tough
yeah but we'll make it through
we'll make it through whoa
i think i'm gonna
go in yeah
i'm gonna try this milk i'll join you
i'll join you at the party
[Music]
so it's been a while since i've spoken
to a musician about working with so many
high-profile producers so what i want to
do here is just hit you with a few names
and mom you and i battle the bomb right
now
you just tell me the first thing that
comes to your mind cut this off
it doesn't stop it doesn't stop it
actually kind of just grows if anything
like whoa
we might not be at the peak yet we might
not have hit
the peak of that hot sauce quite yet
so i'll just hit you with some producers
you tell me the first thing that comes
to mind man i can't
when you think about their process in
the lab
diddy
maestro extraordinaire
bro yeah
no way i'm going for the grape soda
okay what a hack this is the first time
17 seasons the milk doesn't do it yeah
first time somebody's brought grape soda
game changer
okay
pharrell varela's all things
come on man
i can't
i know i know i know what you're going
through i know what you're going through
i can't go no further
how do i get this off me man i know i
know
how
so you can do whatever you want but this
is where i try to talk to you okay
so
that wing
is the worst which one the one that we
just ate
by miles and miles and miles it's worse
than these last two
[Music]
these next two will kind of feel like a
walk in the park by comparison
the fans will root for you and we're so
close too bad i can't hear him
i'm gonna keep reacting i'm not doing
that i i and i'm done oh
that's really hot oh my god
[Music]
ice cream coming in
yeah i can't
all right well i just have a couple more
questions then
we'll bring this to a close all right
okay
[Music]
this is a setup man
what makes shaq and biggies you can't
stop the rain one of your favorite rap
tracks
man
cause big was so great on it
and
[Music]
i thought shaq was gonna be bad and he
really wasn't
they caught ill versus ill melodies they
just found their way through that track
what do you think is the most perfect
biggie line
off the top of your head without
thinking about it too much
oh man
you [ __ ] got some audacity you sold a
million now you half of me get off my
dick kick it [ __ ]
[Music]
the last dab forever a mystery yeah just
forever mystery cool
to close things out i want to jump in
the time machine
go back because we're now just a few
months past the 15-year anniversary of
hell hath no fury wow you've described
as the darkest best record hands down
with your brain melting tongue ablaze
while you enjoy your ice cream what
makes hell hath no fury the perfect rap
album
there was absolutely positively not one
compromise on that album
not one compromise lyrically
not one compromise beat wise
i don't think we ever thought about
making a hit i don't think we ever
thought about doing anything other than
making just the hardest hardest record
you know it was a tough time
but it made for
a great great great album
pusha t
the hot ones interview mercifully has
come to an end and now there's nothing
left to do but roll out the red carpet
for you this camera this camera this
camera let the people know what you have
going on in your life
i can't even think
but
new pusha d album coming soon
um
man
i see y'all i'll see you all this summer
i'm i'll be in i'll be festivals
everywhere y'all come check me
i'm gonna be fighting out people on
twitter bro i don't care
i i meant eight through ten is bad just
letting you know that when they come at
you
wait a minute who who finishes this
like a lot of people
no
hey what's going on hot ones fans shawn
evans just want to say thank you so much
for watching today's episode and if
while you were watching you thought to
yourself you know what i would love to
try that at home well guess what now you
can because the season 17 hot ones hot
sauce box is now available heatness.com
heatness.com heatness.com to get your
hands on the sauces look at how it looks
on the inside so pretty
oh we got boom mic problems the box is
so big and you know what always with the
cautionary tale
be careful around the eyes hot ones
season 17 the full sauce lineup now
available
at heatness.com
[Music]